the summers biggest blockbuster might
not be coming to a theater near you but
to committee rooms on Capitol Hill
robert muller is to testify before the
House Judiciary and intelligence
committees Republicans want to shut the
door on the investigation Democrats who
control the hearings hope new details of
Donald Trump's conduct could lead to
impeachment or hurt his re-election
efforts it falls to Congress to respond
to the crimes lies and other wrongdoing
of President Trump no one not even the
president is above the law Muller a
former FBI director was in charge of the
most extensive and most watched special
investigation involving a u.s. president
since Watergate brought down Richard
Nixon 40 years ago the two-volume nearly
five hundred page report was completed
in March a redacted version was made
public in April it showed substantial
evidence of Russian meddling in the u.s.
election 34 people were indicted and
several convicted including some close
to Trump in his campaign administration
and private life there the facts end and
the spin begins the investigation did
not establish a conclusive link between
the Trump campaign and foreign
interference I'm having a good day - it
was called no collusion no obstruction
well not quite
in a May press conference Muller made
his only public comments about the
investigation they threw a lot of gray
on to Trump's preferred black and white
take if we had had confidence that the
president clearly did not commit a crime
we would have said so we did not however
make a determination as to whether the
President did commit a crime the
Constitution empowers Congress to do it
justice department policy blocks charge
try and remove a president from office
Democrats remain split over impeachment
Muller has said his verbal testimony
today will go no further than the
written report so like any big
blockbuster the hearings could be this
summer smash hit or a total flop
you